in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to an episode of
genius brain podcast we have one of my
favorite favorite guests ever returning
we got boozy buzzing ttan oh the
light-skinned wonder of the world
dude okay y'all y'all don't know that I
was looking at that instead of a camera
hi you guys probably don't know this but
I blow David up outside of like outside
of like doing shows and [ __ ] like he's
one of the few people were like
something happens I'm like David let me
know yes and you know what dude you're
always such a ride-or-die with it like
you you give when I need advice you give
great advice but yeah but also like you
you take the right you usually take the
right side and like if I feel like I'm
not on the right side of things you'll
be like oh you give me he'll talk me you
can't talk me off the ledge you know
like you know what I feel like too with
advice and I think I'm when I learned
when I was younger
giving advice is something that's very
difficult and sometimes when I hear
people who give advice I think a lot of
people are smart enough to a certain
extent where they can they just want to
hear themselves say this [ __ ] you know
what I mean they just need to say their
thoughts out loud so it's not it's not
the advice givers job to sway somebody a
certain way it's just to allow them to
think out their thoughts now if they go
somewhere really bad then you could
probably suggest something be like well
how about this
right and this give somebody some stuff
to think about because if people are
just entrenched in their ideas they're
not gonna change it either way right
you're just gonna just keep digging that
hole deeper and deeper and deeper and I
just have to know that I can just do my
job and just say what I have to say like
for example there was a buddy of mine
who I knew that his wife was stepping
out on him right I knew this [ __ ] and so
my thing is I'm friends with both of
them so I had to go ahead and tell him
to the side I was like eh bro you know
that your wife is step he goes oh yeah
like we're in an open relationship
that's what he said and I looked at him
and I was like no you're not right and
he was like what do you mean and so this
is my position where you know I could
let things ride out or I could save my
peace because I had to save my peace
because it's gonna be on my
consciousness friend let's be real
though but when you looked at him dead
in the eyes and said no you're not you
said enough because you gonna go home
and think about
his own conclusions but you know like I
said you know yes I was like I said what
do you mean I was like because in an
open relationship that means two people
are participating all right I was like
she's [ __ ] around you're not so this
is not an open relationship that's you
being okay being a [ __ ] cuck so I
said I'm gonna say what I'm gonna say if
you're happy with her you're happy with
her right but I know you you don't
believe in this open relationship if you
were a open relationship person then it
would be fine but what actually happened
is and you know is that you caught her
cheating and that she somehow convinced
you because you're being a little [ __ ]
that it's okay for her to cheat because
you want her to be happy so unless
you're willing to participate in that
open relationship thing and that's just
you being a little [ __ ] I'm just gonna
say what I'm gonna say and what I say
what to him was way worse by the way
this is the nice version and I was like
imma say what I said what I said and I'm
just gonna leave it at then I'll never
mention to you again but that's
something for you to think about you
know what though in that I know that's
not the topic at hand today but I gotta
say like seriously in that situation
that was the best thing you could have
said for him because if that's what
she's gonna do then he needs to dig
inside himself and maybe there's a
person that he is interested in go sleep
with that person and if she gets mad or
if you don't feel right about it now you
know that there's morality differences
you guys that are so big that that's
gonna come up again in the relationship
she thinks of love is one thing and you
think of love as another so that's a
really big test of a relationship but
also [ __ ] that [ __ ] I mean I think I
could as long as like its stated out
there but I'm more of a I don't know I
okay I'm on the same page as you
cuz I thought about this we actually
talked about it in a JK video one time
because I said as it stands right now no
I could not do an open relationship but
if I'm with someone for 20-30 years and
we have this like it's like a soul
connection almost I'm like is the
physical body really that important and
then also there's so many celebrities
like Will Smith and Jada that have open
relationships I think really I thought
that was hearsay that's for real that's
for real she said well I will say I
heard she talked about in a podcast
didn't hear the clip but that is what I
heard and there's a lot of other
celebrities that are it's in successful
relationships that are open so my
thought process is what do they know
what have
they experience that we don't know so
right now I couldn't do it but am I
gonna close the book on in the future
I don't know uh yeah my buddy Ricky
shucks was in an open relationship I
think he did a video on that too I think
like the closest I mean I guess I don't
know this is considered an open
relationship cause I've been with
somebody where we were together but then
we you know [ __ ] around with other
people but it was more like open dating
yeah me because it wasn't like I was
like sole committed to her yeah I think
like once that soul commit happens
that's when it gets a little murky it's
like I don't think I want somebody else
touching you angry sexual real fast I
break you
maybe hand in your penis hand in my
penis but yeah I don't know you know for
a rainy day
yeah you know what we should do well
full stop it there and then we'll unpack
all of our thoughts like through the
show and then maybe we'll get to the
conclusion I don't know I mean so what
Boze wanted to talk about today I think
it's just a hot topic and obviously I
went over with a with my buddy edrick on
this podcast but you know the whole
world is on fire yes dude holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yo I'm so curious because we are
really living in history I never thought
I would be on curfew during quarantine
during exam yo it's 1 p.m. in Beverly
Hills in Santa Monica oh that's because
white people will now that so yeah and
then I'm kind of curious like when this
is written in the history books 50 years
from now we're gonna be like well maybe
not 50 [ __ ] I don't think I'm gonna make
it to 80 I you know 40 years from now I
think I'll hit 70 um which I'm nervous
about because 70 I'm tired already David
I can't imagine being 70 I can't I can't
imagine being more tired
yeah in this moment you know here's my
thing though like I think I'm
this is going to happen right that this
has to be the last straw it literally
does the chapter in your history books
kids in the future when you see the [ __ ]
on this year in 2020 is going to be
about 900 pages that's happening right
now
it's [ __ ] unreal yeah it's I I mean
it makes it makes I hate to say it but
you know it makes sense because a lot of
what we're experiencing especially
online because there's of course like
and we can definitely talk more about
like all of like the black lives matter
movement and like what's going on all I
call them the boots on the ground but
for a lot of us online a lot of what I
see is people that are so surprised by
all different opinions and I'm like the
Internet is just a giant cesspool of us
finding out that not everyone thinks
like that
and it's hard to digest and understand
that there are some people that are
super [ __ ] racist even 19 and 20 year
olds that are out here tweeting about
what this isn't important all lives
matter and they're the same age as us
and younger and it's crazy to see that
this mentality with the Amish slowly we
thought was slowly being eradicated is
actually still alive and well and
they're still loud and and they want
changes in their own fashion which is
mind-boggling for me it's so much for so
many of us to digest yeah once right now
that I don't even know where to start I
mean I can start with this is number one
if you tell me all lives matter one more
time I'm gonna kick you and your [ __ ]
puss we're gonna kick you your [ __ ]
your body actually let's make a gender
neutral my big toe is going right up
your butthole look at this stupid
[ __ ]
I don't understand why it's so hard for
people to understand why all lives
matter doesn't make sense
black lives matter say the one last time
black lives matter does not mean all
life's don't matter black lives matter
means that black lives haven't mattered
so until they matter
then all lives suddenly matter that's
all that it means
it literally means all lives matter
that's the purpose of it it's not to
take away or diminish your [ __ ] life
and what you go through but it's to
highlight what this group of people is
going through and I don't understand how
you don't get it
yeah and the
the thing is is that like I'm just gonna
[ __ ] say yeah every single day people
act like non-minority lives always
matter like it's not a question whether
non-minority lives matter or not but
apparently it is a question whether
black lives matter or not yeah so the
reason why we are saying that phrase is
because apparently we have to remind you
that black lives do matter because you
don't think that they do dads that's
that's why we have to say it I can't
believe I'm saying this I'll paraphrase
a tick-tock I saw it I actually
summarized it pretty well I rather than
just describing it I'll kind of like
just say it but in the like in the video
she's like hey hey guys my house is on
fire there's a picture of a house on
fire in the background she's like hey
this house is on fire I'm gonna go save
it and then somebody else's flashes over
their house in the background but it's
not on fire and they're like but what
about my house and the person is like
well this house this house is on fire so
I have to go over there and the person's
like but what about mine and we're like
your house isn't on fire your house has
never been on fire this house has been
burning and spreading like wildfire for
years so that that's why it's a thing
it's not that your life doesn't matter
your life does matter and your life has
mattered variously ours haven't and I
even saw this thing the other day where
it was a guy he posted a tweet and he
said I was arrested once for a
counterfeit $20 bill it's sometimes a
story that I tell at dinner parties for
George Floyd that was a death sentence
and he was like and that is white
privilege and I'm like that's big that's
heavy and you know I have to say to that
me I am a black woman but I also have a
lot of light-skinned privileges and I'm
very very aware of that but I mean I
might am I gonna like not speak up I
didn't have somebody to say like you're
a little too light to speak on this and
I'm like him what the [ __ ] did you just
[ __ ] say to me and I'm talking to you
like just I I can't I can't that was
really [ __ ] gross because we should
all be in this together and that's why I
was curious to talk to you about it too
because like bro bring the minorities
together where we at where we know it's
it's it's weird when I I've been dealing
with a lot of you know people say that
we have to police our own people right
and I do understand that to a certain
extent I really do believe it
just because sometimes I always feel
weird when people are like you know
Asian people don't like black people and
it's hard for me to kind of sign in on
that because that's not how I grew up
that's not around the Asian people that
I grew up to but I do understand the the
microaggressions that a lot of Asian
people have in this country I'm not
excusing this behavior but you have to
understand that you do have that micro
aggression because of the stuff that was
taught to you when you came to this
country
it wasn't stuff that you had before you
came here back but you were taught that
when you came here back right so when we
opened up these businesses in this in
this country well it wasn't a fall
tomorrow and they gave us this loans and
then you heard this this rhetoric of
black people are like this black people
are like that
thank God from my parents think I'm my
dad's a pastor that he doesn't he didn't
subscribe to any of these thoughts I
even had a conversation with my mom and
she was talking about how pissed she was
about all this stuff that's happened to
black people she was how terrible is
this right and she and she even equated
to like okay like she said that if me
working at this store right every bad
thing that has happened to me in the
store it would suck if I said that oh
you know five percent of the customers
that came and robbed us and they treated
me like crap races the ninety five
percent of the customers that I have a
great relationship with right and if
somebody who's not from this country
that has a general disposition to hate
this culture because of what's been
taught to her can understand it and
she's even [ __ ] speak English you can
to my mom my mom can do that you know
what else you bring up a really good
point that reminds me of something this
it's like where does this hate come from
like what is the issue and in my opinion
the issue is fear because people are
taught that black people are scary that
we're violent that we rob people that we
have guns and wearing gangs and what is
that it's scared people
and so in when in order to fight your
own fear sometimes you have to try to
rise against it with anger and hatred
and I think that that's where a lot of
that comes from it's fear
and I even think that a lot of this this
[ __ ] with cops it once again it's fear
like it's like what is this big scary
black man gonna do to me and one of the
things that we have to do is educate
that black people are not scary we are
not we do not have
scary fangs and we just want to steal
your money we don't want to break into
your house like that's [ __ ] and
saying like there are white people to do
that [ __ ] to and I think that we as a
society we're so small-minded the right
rather than categorizing people by their
mentalities and the psychology of and
how they think we decide to define
people by what they look like because
it's easier for us our brain isn't gonna
say like oh these are good people these
are bad people we're just like well that
one's white and that one's black so that
one must be good when that one must be
bad one because we're so [ __ ] dumb
yeah and and we we put ourselves in that
pigeonhole we are not dumb we're smarter
than that and I'm like where is the
narrative that we should look at people
for how they think and how they act
rather than in the way that they look
yeah I mean just to put that into an
example of something that happened not
too long ago I did a video on this years
ago I think people have already
forgotten about like the whole falando
Castille thing
so if Alana Castile was in his car with
his girlfriend right and he was pulled
over cop came up to him asked him for
his license and his registration and he
goes officer I just want to let you know
that I do have a firearm here and he
goes he goes okay cool but don't reach
for it and he goes I'm not reaching for
it I'm getting my license and
registration he goes don't reach for it
and he just unloads a whole clip on him
in his car boom boom boom boom boom kill
him murders him in the car as he told
him he had a he did exactly what he was
supposed to do he looked at the officer
in his face he's an officer I have a
fire I'm in my car I want to let you
know that and he goes cool just don't
grab he goes okay I'm grabbing for my
license is registration he goes don't
grab for it don't grab for any goes cap
cap cap kills this man right and as he's
saying that he goes I told him not to
grab for him I told him not to grab for
it now this really does attest to the
fact of this fear that is taught to
scare be scared of the black man mm-hmm
he reached for a license and
registration that you asked for told you
about the firearm that he has in his car
which is what he's supposed to do and he
got murdered on sight because his brain
was like oh big scary black man
definitely gonna shoot me big scary
black man afraid of the cops he's gonna
shoot me and drive away his little
fantasies went wild and he reacted to
them and so when you see these type of
situations it's and I mentioned this
before on the previous podcast [ __ ]
these these riders and the looters I'm
not
[ __ ] with him a hundred percent right
and we do understand that there's a
problem in the media that cut that's
trying to deter what this whole issue is
about they want to deflect it to look at
these looters look at these rioters
that's not the point of this there's a
reason why it got to this point but
we're not talking about why our country
is in this state we're just talking
about the negative stuff that's
happening because our country is in this
- we got to talk about the reason why
that's the point that's the [ __ ]
movement so when we had this situation
where I keep reading is by the way if
you've been to the protest the it's not
hearsay the the anti fuh [ __ ] these
random people just throwing random but
there aren't even part of BLM they're
[ __ ] there yeah it's there they're
there just tagging [ __ ] up just to tag
[ __ ] up busting [ __ ] windows and
looting it they're not actually a part
of the [ __ ] movement they're just
there to steal yes and you guys are
convoluting the message with these
people that aren't a part of what we
want to talk about right and like I this
is something I'm very passionate about
because it's hot take it's also
something that happened a lot with that
like the women's movement and like
saying believe all women if you if you
truly believe that in the middle of an
important movement that there are not
people that are there to capitalize and
take advantage of the movement for their
own benefit you are wrong like there are
always people that are there to do
something for to push their own [ __ ]
agenda and you have to you have to be
aware of that and you have to start to
differentiate those people and a lot of
people I do i I really how do you feel
about like the the riots kind of in like
the destruction of things I mean I I
know who's doing it and I know who's not
doing it right
but it's just I have to be very careful
about blanket statements because you
could do that with anything right
whenever there's somebody that's going
to find an opportune moment to do
something selfish people will do that
right it's just going to happen but my
I'm not with rioters and looters I'm not
with that [ __ ] I'm with the peaceful
protests I'm with people being angry I
think people should be able to protest
be angry scream get loud as long as
they're not [ __ ] [ __ ] up that's okay
so but the problem that I have is though
the rioting and the looting it's just
it's such a huge deterrent from the
message right so I think sometimes when
I said when I say something like I
understand why it's happening they think
that I'm for the rioting and looting I
think that it's okay it's absolutely not
okay dude the LA riots in 92 we're
[ __ ] insane
yeah like this is coming from a
korean-american people in k-town LA they
had to be up on their roofs with guns to
shoot people down because people were
coming inside to rob them and kill them
yeah you know dude especially with the
small businesses inside I'm so sad okay
I have really really mixed feelings on
this let me just tell you like my and
actually I'll try to I'll put like a
little little modern spin on it okay so
this is this is crazy but we're gonna
get there you know how let's say
something happens in the YouTube or the
Internet community maybe even politics
or some [ __ ] like that and there's a
huge scandal and everyone's talking
about it and talking about it and the
person sweeps it under the rug just
constantly and in that the only way that
the person finally says something is
when people online are so loud and I say
this about the YouTube community because
in like politics they have a full-time
job they don't give a [ __ ] what you're
saying on Twitter but there's people on
YouTube when you start spreading things
about them and putting out assumptions
you're now affecting their job and their
livelihood and that is why they are
finally pressed to say something so in
this particular instance with you know
the riots and the protests I believe
like you said back it with the Rodney
King I think it was in like 93 there was
a lot going on and it started off with
peaceful protest and nobody was
listening
nobody was because it's really easy to
sweep it under the rug when people are
just marching peacefully because yeah
they are making a statement well why do
something why so then when the rioting
and the looting started happening which
I mean a lot of it happened to small
businesses which i think is absolutely
[ __ ] horrible but that costs Los
Angeles over 1 billion dollars the
insurance companies had to pay it out
the cities had to pay it out and money
talks yeah and after that they they put
a lot of parameters in place from
creating a system where cops could
actually kind of rat out other cops
comfortably because
these people are taught in dangerous
situations to protect each other no
matter what that's instilled in them to
always protect each other so even
outside of the line of duty like when
they're just in the office they might
hear something off-color from a cop and
they don't want to report it because
it's ingrained in them that they sort
they're supposed to have each other's
backs
but LAPD was like not wrap these
[ __ ] out they started making
sure that everyone Road to to a car so
that officers didn't make reactive moves
because that's what's happening like
when they don't feel protected they get
scared and the scared man with a gun is
[ __ ] dangerous
so they made sure that they had people
riding - - a car they put all of these
things in place and since then which I
was surprised to hear about that
shooting that you told me about the LAPD
is one of the few organizations that
hasn't had a lot of [ __ ] like this
happen in like almost 30 years
well the falando Castille thing was was
not in l.a yeah okay yeah so I mean as
from and I I read about all of this from
like a person that was like a history
teacher that cited a lot of sources and
overall economic protests they make they
make the most noise because money talks
and they feel like they have to respond
so although I am NOT I'm not saying I'm
for the rioting and the looting I'm
really not but I it's what happens when
people emotionally can't there's so much
emotion that they can't stay here and
organize a boycott what are you gonna
boycott like the economic stuff really
really really does work hurts yeah so
when when there's a lot of emotion tied
into it it turns into destruction and
destruction costs money and I actually
believe that if this stuff continues
they have no choice but to listen or
they're gonna continue to hemorrhage
money yeah I just I I don't think I can
me personally I don't think I can
emotionally deal with this again that's
why I'm being so vocal about it right
now
cuz I I just I just don't want to deal
with this anymore I don't think anybody
wants to deal with this [ __ ] anymore
I don't want to hear another all AIIMS
matter [ __ ] I don't want to hear
another person just being slain simply
because of the color of their skin I
just don't want that right I want that
[ __ ] to be very few and far between so
we could pull out those bad apples but
right now we're talking about a few bad
apples it's not just a few [ __ ] bad
apples it's a system that's [ __ ] up
yeah
not a few bad apples and I want people
to get that [ __ ] correct it's like
okay it's a couple of cops yeah a couple
of cops but the whole system is [ __ ]
that causes those bad apples to be there
so don't worry about the bad apples
yeah and make them pay but let's fix the
system behind it right let's let's
attack that for a second because we do
we really need to talk about that [ __ ]
because there's even stuff where people
are putting out you know there was his
post of I think it was in New York there
was these cops that were kneeling with
the protesters and then 45 minutes later
they're beating the [ __ ] out of them
Jesus it's like you know what's what's
wrong what's wrong with this picture
right and then we have some of these
influencers my god let's not even talk
about these [ __ ] dude I mean I
just did a video on it on my Instagram
where it was a girl she [ __ ] asked
one of these people who's who's borning
at one of these businesses to stop so
she could hold his drill drill pretend
to drill and board up something to her
boyfriend's taking a [ __ ] photo and
then in the most [ __ ] Becky care and
away she goes thank you you're doing
such a great job
BLM BLM drives off [ __ ] good oh my
lucky I'm okay and so and then the car
just [ __ ] drives away and I'm sitting
there just dumbfounded are you [ __ ]
kidding me like this is what I'm saying
this is why people get upset when they
say you're sometimes your post don't do
anything and I say this before you post
something right I appreciate everybody
appreciates that stuff but believe in
the cause first before you say something
because that's the reason why this
becomes a cyclical issue is because you
just say it but you don't act upon it
yeah cuz it's the cool thing to go ahead
and put a post it's a cool thing to go
ahead and say BLM because you want to be
a part of something that's happening now
because it's hip or you're afraid that
you're gonna get [ __ ] on because there's
no conviction behind your words and your
actions
yeah when things happen again it happens
for a [ __ ] reason because you
actually don't believe in this stuff
that you're putting out it's it's using
it's literally using something that's a
very important issue for life was
another girl those they've been writing
these people out but it's a girl she's
standing in her little fitness clothing
as she's standing
in front of a busted in Verizon water
list I said what their arms down super
dramatic and her boyfriend's taking the
photo and she was cool got it and they
start walking off it's like how [ __ ]
dare you dude yo you know why okay this
might be a little nitpicky but one that
I don't really particularly I've been
seeing this so so much is when somebody
doesn't post anything about black lives
matter but they'll scream cap they're
like $20 donation and then they're just
like make sure you support and it's like
and it's just like a generalize like
George like fun or something it's not
even I don't know I feel it put some
thought in between and behind it it just
feels like you're like let me post this
so that people don't get mad at me you
know and I mean I will say there's been
some people where I have seen that it
made some huge contributions like you
know like five hundred thousand dollars
something that cuz you never know how
much money somebody has like that really
could be a lot for them but like yo if
you're donating $10 and screen capping
it like just just pulsed the [ __ ]
link honestly like just post the [ __ ]
language it's like you're like clap for
me yeah that's why even some of these
influencers - I'm just gonna say this
before I even you know go ahead and talk
my [ __ ] I do appreciate any help and I
think that it even if you're in in
sincere at least you're doing something
I get that but people have a problem
with virtue signaling a lot right yes
because it came comes off very that in
sincerity just bleeds out and then we
have to absorb that [ __ ] right like I
like I saw a video of an influencer he
goes you know hey like I just want to
say I have friends out there that told
me that I shouldn't do this video
because you know it's gonna be a bad
look for my brands I don't care about
brands good for you Fido
good job oh I'm sorry it's like that
came off to me so insincere it's like
why did you have to your the whole 10
minute message in the beginning was
about how awesome you are
that you hadn't say no I'm not gonna
take these thousands of dollars because
I've got to make sure that people know
about this it's like okay dude that's
the epitome of verse you're signaling
yeah it's the epitome of it and I feel
like some people don't understand I I
will say though that there are some
people where they feel this pressure
from social media around them but they
don't get it it has
really bled into them they haven't been
affected by it in any way so it doesn't
feel like it hits close to them you know
I actually had a person that it was like
a somebody commented on one of my
friends instagrams that was like
basically saying like why are you guys
doing all of this
why are you condoning this there was
rioting that happened near my mom's
house
I shouldn't have to be scared for my mom
and I'm like well I hate to [ __ ] say
it but you weren't listening until it
came right to your doorstep and you were
scared for your mom huh yeah you know
and like that's just facts it doesn't
mean that it's a good thing it doesn't
mean that I condone it but you would
have sat there and brushed it under the
rug unless you felt like you had to and
even some of these influencers they also
would have brushed it under the rug
because it's bad for brands until they
felt like it hurts their public image to
not say something yeah and you know what
I'm complaining about it but honestly I
don't know what the answer for that will
be yeah it makes me feel like I'm one of
those people that will never be happy so
I'm just [ __ ] on people just to [ __ ]
on people and it does feel that way
sometimes it does I feel I guess the
thing is is that I feel like there's a
right way and a wrong way to do it and
I'd it's a gray area for me I don't know
what it is but I know that sometimes I'm
sure you guys feel that way too there
are times where you look at something
and you're like I want to appreciate
this but it doesn't feel right so I'm
just gonna look away and I think that's
what we're getting a lot with these yeah
and then you know we read I read stuff
about what's that [ __ ] guy he's he's
the brother of the the [ __ ] Oh Paul I
don't know the [ __ ] Logan Paul's
brother Oh Oh Jake Paul Jake Paul ride
with him with him like rating the whole
and him like alluding to it's like [ __ ]
aren't you a gajillion air dude they
were saying but like they're like oh no
Jay Paul didn't loot anything and I'm
like but did you guys honestly think
that before he walked out of that door
he didn't say let's get some [ __ ]
content the word content probably left
his mouth five or six times before they
left it's so important for me and this
is something that I dive into a lot I
love doing like industry PR breakdowns
and stuff like that I do them a lot on
my stream and the one thing that I try
to instill in people all the time is
finding intent a lot of times we look at
things like very black and white about
how we feel about them but we never
really dial in and try to figure out
what was this person's intent of putting
this out there and that's that's
I always want to know yeah it's for him
it was to grab great content yeah it was
the difference between what he did and
his brother recording a dead Japanese
man hanging from a [ __ ] tree content
content he's like a brother like brother
exactly there is no [ __ ] difference
and the sad thing is is that they are a
representation of what a majority of
people in this country want to see and
how much they don't give a [ __ ] about
their intent they just like oh he's a
very entertaining person to me and I
want to be like him because he has a lot
of money and that's all that [ __ ]
matters and so people that follow him
are the vast majority that's the sad
reflection yeah you could go ahead and
put out whatever video you want about
these two [ __ ] trash bag human beings
but at the end of the day their pockets
get bigger because people want to see
[ __ ] from them that's all that matters
and I feel like so often we forget that
not everyone things like us and not
everyone is going to agree with us and
sometimes we're like but I don't get it
it's so simple this person is greedy or
using these things for views and we see
it but it's almost naive of us to expect
millions of other people are gonna see
things that same way you know they may
not even be able to see the big picture
they're just like I think the content
good yeah isn't that so sad though like
the human aspect is just always ignored
that's that's that's why I get so
disappointed and that's why I don't have
a problem calling people out on their
[ __ ] [ __ ] like there was the the
the lady in the malaysian miss miss
malaysia did you see what she wrote no
so she wrote this whole Instagram story
post where she says basically it is the
racism in America it is what it is
if you just need to get this she goes if
you're a colored person in America you
shouldn't complain because you chose it
what she says you chose to be a colored
person in America so why complain let me
read that to you it's not what she said
do David do you have any bleach I made
the wrong choice I need to change back
so this is what she wrote
Samantha Katie by the way okay to the
black people no oh my god it really says
that shit's tight washes this girl she's
she spit hot fire
I hope y'all are sitting down to the
black people relax that you read
something you read and you just like
take it as a challenge it makes you
stronger it makes you stronger this is a
Malaysian pageant winner by the way
because you know she's with the people
samantha katie is her name or also as i
like to call her cut back
you chose to be born as a colored person
in america for a reason to learn a
certain lesson accept it as it is
till now hunger and poverty still exists
it is what it is it's inevitable best
you can do is remain calm protect heart
and don't allow it to crumble that's
your responsibility of course this is to
the ones who understand this level and
state of mind it's not for everyone
everyone grows at a different rate
that's her whole state she was hacked
I'm trying to I'm trying to help I'm
trying to help her out the black people
already [ __ ] up I love what she says
that it's a lesson that we're supposed
to learn but she wants us to learn that
lesson and just sit there and take it
like wow really learned my lesson don't
evangelize it don't I mean there's a lot
that I could take from it but there's so
much of that they're so ridiculous hard
to understand there's there's no
response it's almost like you you ever
used like one of those random jet
randomly generated things if you think
she used one that was like use the most
offensive things possible in a current
in a current event and go and she's like
this looks great I'm gonna post this
that is you know above all it's it's
amazing to me that she genuinely thought
that that would that would work oh sure
can I just read her apology though
she has an apology now the best I don't
yes yes I do hear you I'm sorry I know
you're hurting I know it's unfair I'm
not in your shoes to understand this
fully then you should probably shut the
[ __ ] up then furthermore you asked me to
explain what I meant by black people
chose to be black Oh God is that
throughout my journey I have learned
that we are more than just temporary
physical body like an avatar merely a
tiny speck of dust in the vast infinite
universe are you Neil deGrasse Tyson you
[ __ ] dumb ho what the [ __ ] are you
saying right now we are about to mere
speck of dust in the cosmos that came
out the dingleberry out of my ass talent
show segment for when she won was just
like mr. Roboto or something just her
[ __ ] space galaxy music just exactly
we tend to overlook that from time to
time in our process towards evolution as
a human being on earth we you sound like
an alien [ __ ] robot we chose our body
our family [ __ ] you know what this you
know it she's basically saying on this
she's saying that black is not a race
it's a way that you're acting and you
chose to act that way which is literally
the most racist [ __ ] I've ever heard of
my life just like I've literally been
called the n-word to my face and that
that is more racist no but you chose to
be that that's right go sit and sit down
because it is what it is Blackey anger
translator we need girl honestly I've
been called Blacky by a white girl
before and to this day I think that's
the most offensive thing like I've ever
been wait I think so Blackie Blackie
like like like a cute little nickname
like I eat bein that is so fun yo
Michael che had to stand up where he was
he was talking about he goes like I
don't understand why [ __ ] transsexual
people are so upset by me calling them
[ __ ] [ __ ] white a homegirl that was
a transsexual woman she comes up and she
goes she goes well how would you like it
if I called you Blackie and he goes good
point
what it is about that wire that ie at
the end but uh that's pretty bad good
Blackie I get it she goes we chose our
body our family our place of birth our
name and our lessons from the path we
take tailor-made for us [ __ ]
that's so not even facts it's unreal you
don't choose your [ __ ] body that's
you get what you get [ __ ] she acts like
when the sperm hit the [ __ ] ovary
this [ __ ] had a conversation
with the ovaries like a you won't be
black Asian why to what pierce my
[ __ ] head inside you what we gonna be
David you know maybe maybe she as the
enlightened one as maybe we forgot about
a collective memory that she still
retains where upon birth she was select
she was allowed to select her race there
were all these colors and she said I
just want if she honestly if she wrote
that [ __ ] I'd understand she goes when I
came into the universe as a speck of
dust I remember I remember when I saw
the ovary I chose my ethnicity I said oh
this [ __ ] is crazy now I understand
dude that fall out of OS or more yes I
understand a lot of people have shared
that I could have phrased my content
differently and I said that I am
responsible for my words I will make
sure I try to articulate my speech in a
proper manner no you want platformers
you don't know how to this is so [ __ ]
bad so let me continue this real quick
mmm-hmm to clear the air yes I did
poorly yes I did poorly articulate
myself when writing black people chose
to be black and to the black people
relax and take it as a challenge that
makes you stronger no [ __ ]
if I had been more attentive in how I
wrote it no that's not it the message
would have been understood no it
wouldn't have as a heartfelt message to
all victims no it's not of racism be it
of any color yes my mother is Chinese
Malaysian father is Brazilian and my
foster parents who raised me up are
Indian Malaysian Wow question popped up
wondering that you think she's
obviously a minority and I think that
when she won two people felt like she
represented this minority yeah do you
think that cuz this is a thing sometimes
do you think that she's trying to
distance herself from that culture and
not be a minority and be closer to white
culture I think a lot of people don't
understand this when they when they're
[ __ ] sitting up at their ivory tower
when they used to be in the slums they
forget what it was like yes right they
set up in their [ __ ] ivory tower and
they look down on people and they feel
like I earned this I deserved this I
worked for it and none of you works for
it and they go oh oh I could see why
they they used to treat me like this is
because they didn't have money and they
were savages and I'm not a savage
anymore I'm not a little [ __ ] savage
it's [ __ ] ridiculous listen I
understand that to the minimal amount of
sense of where like sometimes with me
like I'll go back home Sacramento right
not like this but I'm saying like it
when I go to the hood I because I'm in
the hood anymore I get a little scared
yeah because I look like a little [ __ ]
now okay I don't know how to like you
know I'm saying I don't know how to act
anymore like what's up I'm like
sometimes you know I mean I forget where
I came from it's like hold on a second
you want that [ __ ] Bahamas on that
block [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you so I forget
sometimes where I come from to in that
sense but not yes
not at all not at all and like when we
when we like we dude I was in I can't
even where I was just five years ago
like I can't believe where I am now and
I'm so [ __ ] happy but my thought
process and that is not to turn my back
on that it's to try to lend a helping
hand like do whatever okay like [ __ ]
one of the things that I've been really
big on is that with all this stuff going
on black lives matter I feel like we
forgot about the a lot of effects of
kovat that have happened yeah and
something that really upset me was just
the other day I was posting about this
[ __ ] Beverly Hills in Santa Monica had
decided to curfew at 1:00 p.m.
their restaurants were closing
restaurants had to close at 6:00 like
every look the pot shop was closed the
whole world was shutting down David I
was panicking [ __ ] but but my thought on
that was like delivery restaurants
everything was shut down David
have you ever had a time where rent was
do you know that you got a grace period
and you're like [ __ ] alright it's the
30th maybe you were depressed last week
and you're like alright I'm gonna grind
it out for these next six days and I'm
gonna pay rent now imagine the whole
world shows last week that was literally
last know what you're talking about I
still got some hood ass tendencies when
I got a bill to pay and like they gonna
give me a five great five-day grace
period i'ma hold on as money as long as
possible imagine you have to go and make
it and I'm yeah I've done that several
times in my life especially moving out
here in LA first year and [ __ ] like that
so immediately my thoughts went to
people that plan - maybe deliver on post
mates for six days straight and then
make up you know they tail into their
rent and now they can only deliver from
9:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m. or what 9:00 a.m.
to 6:00 p.m. and now everyone's trying
to do it so I started the other day I
started posting about this I'm telling
people to like tip your tip your [ __ ]
post mates and then I actually actually
just randomly bought food from Baja
Fresh like right before curfew was
ending and I called the dude I was like
yo just keep the food and I'll like give
you a tip I tipped him 35 dollars and
like I like I gave him the food because
like I'm thinking like bro if I was
ending my shift trying to just get as
much as I could it's 5:30 it's the last
order of the day I don't have time to
get food all these restaurants closing
like that's what I'm always thinking
about and I'm never gonna for cuz that
was me I'm never gonna forget where I
[ __ ] came from so it's it says a lot
about somebody's character that when
they do get to the top that they're just
gonna look down on everyone I don't [ __ ]
with that yeah I don't [ __ ] with that
either man I mean it's it's people find
it amazing to they go oh when you go
back to Sacramento right your hometown
they're like don't you find it really
boring it's like no I still kept all my
friends that I had since high school
what about you friends with people that
you knew back in the day well every year
since high school since I was 14 we have
a friends giving Thanksgiving and then
we have a Christmas dinner and we still
do it till this day I'm [ __ ] 31 years
old we still do it till this [ __ ] day
dude I love it I do the same [ __ ] and it
says a lot about people that moved out
here in LA and then they forgot about
all their old friends all their
childhood friends and all their friends
are just people to have clout you know
oh if you don't have if you don't have a
quarter of a million followers then like
how are we gonna collab what's the point
it's it's so [ __ ] dumb and you know
Tim said it the best to I we keep seeing
this repetitive post online where people
say this they go oh people in LA are so
[ __ ] fake you can't find real
friendship here it's like aren't you a
[ __ ] influencer why did you move to
LA did you come here to make friends or
did you come here to [ __ ] leech off
people and go ahead and get a big
following you came here for the same
purpose they did you're not any [ __ ]
better if you came here for friendship
and bonds and you didn't get that I
understand but you came here to be a
part of entertainment you came here to
[ __ ] network so you got what you put
out yeah so how dare you [ __ ] on other
people for doing the exact same thing
that you do see the people that I've met
here yeah they're in entertainment but
they're all from this city they're
actually born and raised in LA and
they're the nicest [ __ ] most
down-to-earth people I've ever met yeah
maybe it's the people that you choose to
hang around yes mm-hmm
take a little personal responsibility
right so it's odd that you're in a place
where you came here to take take and
take and then you go I can't believe
people are taking from me yeah there was
a there was a pop a group on YouTube
that was pretty popular on his spill all
the tea but there they're kind of like a
little dispersed now I think but they
were really popular back like 20 2015 or
so like that and I think [ __ ] you guys
but not I didn't watch too much I don't
know too much about them but I knew
somebody that joined it because we were
kind of in a similar boat because I
joined Smosh this way and we got to
talking about it and they felt like you
know they had jumped in with all these
people and nobody was their actual
friend and I'm like yeah that's
something that you have to learn we cast
it into something they're gonna tell you
okay the cameras are on these are all
your best friends now like that that's
how it's gonna be
and we have to a lot of us small town
people that like come here like wait
where are you from originally
Sacramento okay you're from Zelda yeah
that's pretty far up there like it's
like five hours away Drive it's a it's a
small town yeah yeah some of us we come
into this and I actually did I kind of
did that with Smosh too you know we come
into it and we're kind of dumb in the
sense that we're like oh we're supposed
to be friends now we're selling it to
the Internet that were friends and
sometimes you really think that your
friends but you could realize like yo
this is entertainment
this is business these people will throw
you under the bus in a [ __ ] second
you got to hold on to your real people
your real friends like your day ones
because there's some kind of special
connection there between you guys which
is why you gravitated towards each other
but there's so many [ __ ] out
here in LA that are like they're
consciously like that person has half a
million followers they have a million
followers they have two million and then
they get surprised when they get burned
yeah like you were climbing the ranks
and they brought you in like why are you
surprised that this has happened
yeah know what you're getting into there
was a guy that um I mean I knew what I
was getting too I like I prefer
friendships right so I will always work
with people who are friends and I know a
lot of people think that you're not
supposed to work with people are friends
and that that depends on what that
situation is right if it's somebody who
is an employee of you I think develop a
great relationship with them but
understand that work is work business is
business friendship is friendship right
if we're working on a partnership I'd
rather work with the friend first and I
just have to be smart enough to know who
this person is before I get into
business with them just because I should
if I truly am a friend I think the
problem is two people just don't know
what friendship is they don't know what
friends are three it's like you don't
know what who your friends are too many
people say you know that's my friend and
I talked about that wasn't with Mariel
to where I felt like a lot of girls just
kind of hop in friendships a lot and
it's the problem of like I always see
this it's like you meet up you have one
drink and that you've met somebody at a
wedding and then you go off and then you
go [ __ ] BFF it's like whoa whoa what
happened here they're like I
that's my BFF it's like no she's not you
guys you guys clicked for for a hot
second but you actually don't know these
people yet let it simmer friendship
takes a lot of [ __ ] time right
understand who your friends are
understand who your acquaintances are
and understand who your family is yeah
and then everything is good not
everybody has to be your best friend and
you don't have to be liked by everybody
that's okay see I could die with the
friends that I have right now and I'm
okay if I don't add any more additional
friends here I'm fine with that yeah I'm
okay because when I grew up too I didn't
have like too many [ __ ] friends I had
a good subset amount of really close
friends and I had a lot of acquaintances
but when I was younger I thought
everybody was my friend yeah and when I
got hurt by it when I got back
that knot I mean back I never been
really back stat but when I got hurt by
their friendship when they weren't
really there for me as much as I thought
I would be there for them I got hurt
because I've decided to invest myself in
a person that wasn't invested in me yes
yo for a wolf for me I feel like I've
learned over the years that friendship
is that this interesting you say that
because it's like what is it a lot of
people don't know especially as we get
older because I feel like we throw the
term around a lot for me friendship is
if I have your back and you have mine
and and I like the simplest instance of
this was I met this girl just a couple
of months ago and we're kind of like
internet friends and I was having a bad
day and I was starting to tell her about
it like we were like messaging about it
and she was like yo girl hold on let me
get to my computer so I can call you
like on discord like she's like don't
sit there and type she's like just let
me call you and you just been sit out
like let's [ __ ] talk you know and
then to me that was so simple but it was
such a big indicator that she cared
whereas I have some people that like
I've just met in LA over the years where
like if I were to shoot and [ __ ] and
having a bad day and like I'm typing or
something they'll just be like oh damn
like that sucks you know tell me more
but she was like no [ __ ] I'm in your
corner and like that's the ride or die
[ __ ] that I want to see I want to feel
that because to me you're taking your
time you're stepping away from what
you're doing to be there for me and that
speaks volumes yeah the best way in LA
to know if somebody's a really good
friend tell them you're stranded at LAX
on a Sunday and they come pick you up
that's a home yeah you probably just run
through that you're like head about like
what what day and you'll know yeah you
would know there's some people to who
don't even understand why I'm friends
with certain other people they're like
why are you friends with that fool like
he's such a wreck or she's such a wreck
it's like because at the end of the day
that person would always be there for me
and I'll be there for them the way they
are for me right and I said it's like
they're just - that's a not to say his
name but we're really good friends but
the guy is a hyper emotional guy he's
kind of one of those dudes that have the
cyclical issue of always looking at
every single problem the world it only
happens to me it's me me me me me right
it gets really [ __ ] annoying yeah but
he's a really funny guy and I also know
that he comes from a very good place and
he just had a [ __ ] up life so it's
hard for people to be
around him but if people say like oh if
they compared him to somebody else that
I'm more joking and laughing with and
they go who are you close to I always
say him and they're like well you know
he annoys you sometimes I was like yeah
but he's a down ass [ __ ] though
you know what I mean he wouldn't he
wouldn't step on my back to get ahead of
me ever and I would never do the same to
him because I've met a lot of people in
this city who now they've made a career
office Stephanie off of other people's
backs yeah and everybody in our circle
knows this [ __ ] has a little
[ __ ] it's like you could never do
things on your own you could never do
things with your own skills and you're
always known as a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that's why when he sees as it meets
us up can't look us in the [ __ ] eye
he even met me one time and he was like
he was like a man I know we went through
our stuff in the past and you know I
just want to say like I apologize you
know but you know hope we're cool I was
like no we're not gonna be cool cuz
you're staying a little [ __ ] you know
being the Davis know that I am [ __ ] I
probably should have phrased that better
- yeah I was like you still do the same
[ __ ] so you're not any [ __ ]
difference
yeah but I'm civil enough to you where I
could shake your hand and you know we'll
be cool but just don't talk to me again
and walk to the other side and I say it
because I really at that moment I wanted
to sock him in the [ __ ] face because
I I hate people who step on others to
get where they're at and they [ __ ]
ignore somebody else like for me I mean
he's not bigger than I am right but I'm
not even that big but that just goes to
show how short of a trajectory had even
when he was stepping on people right but
he know he found his way and he's making
a living doing what he's doing but the
problem is is that you are forever known
to me as that little [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't have friends he doesn't have any
[ __ ] class and that's the sad part
doesn't have any [ __ ] friends and he
only [ __ ] with people that he could
take something from but he'll never give
something back yeah exactly and you got
it took me a while but you can smell
those people from a mile away they have
like a very special scent they have a
stench and when you're when your eyes
are closed you're like ha ha I love la
having a good time like you you're like
smells bad but I don't know who it is
yeah you know you got to open your eyes
and be like it's that [ __ ] right
there and and there's people have so
many red flags and I i I'd say two years
ago I was at an age where I would choose
to ignore red bags and now I'm like what
is that I see that and they're like what
you talking about of my eyes
that [ __ ] and I will just walk away like
I'm not doing it I'm not a big red flag
person - and even some people that I met
recently now I think people sometimes
misconstrue my gut feeling as somebody
who just dislikes people it's not that I
dislike people right but I know now who
I am I'm very very cement in that [ __ ]
right so I'm not going to change or I'm
not gonna shift my personal pillars for
somebody else if I had this gut feeling
that you were I don't [ __ ] with you I'm
gonna go with my gut feeling until you
prove me otherwise I'm not gonna
mistreat you I'm not gonna do anything
else I'm just not gonna be as giggly and
as laughy around you as other people are
and for me 99% of the time not because
it's a I'm not being prophetic in my
[ __ ] what I'm saying is that it always
turns out to be true it's only a few
people right but for example there's
somebody that's within my circle that I
exercise with right
like I eyes with random people all the
[ __ ] time but there was somebody that
they brought in and I was like hmm I
don't really like this person right and
it's funny one of my friends took me
aside and he was like hey bro you don't
like him be like what do you mean I was
like well we were eating and he was
telling his story either your face was
stone-cold dead Mike you just kind of
went mm-hmm and you just looked away you
walk and you started talking to somebody
else and I was like you don't like him
and he was like why don't you like him I
was like he's a likable person but I
don't think he's a good person there's
something about him there's something
about him where every time he talks he
praises himself and he has this fake
humbleness about him like he he acts
like he's here to learn and listen to
other people and it's it's not true it's
I don't believe it it sounds so
insincere it irritates my spirit yeah if
you're irritating my spirit I'm gonna go
with what my spirit see you have every
right to be like I don't feel good in
this environment with this person and
I'm go this way yeah and I'm still
cordial I'm well you know whenever I
don't see him often obviously now but
you know I cordial shake his hand I say
what's up how you doing but am i
inviting him over are we gonna have side
conversations probably [ __ ] not and
then lo and behold a couple months later
they're like yeah he's kind of a [ __ ]
skis ball I was like yeah he's kind of a
I was like yeah man I was like I call
that [ __ ] right it's something off about
him right and I'm gonna go with that gut
feeling I'll be respectful but at the
same time stay the [ __ ] away from me
yo okay David I got a question for you
yeah and I'm gonna follow up after what
what did you think about me when you met
me the first time you were funny so yo
David you said some [ __ ] to me so in the
first UK news video I don't I think it
might have been the first one that I
ever filmed like with you guys so I was
meeting you for the first time so I'd
met the other people because they came
to film on Smosh I hadn't met you before
but I'm like oh this is you know this is
a dude he's here like you know cool do
whatever right so we filmed the first
episode and after we filmed it the
camera shut off you look me dead in the
eye and you said you're gonna get
attacked in the comments for that was
like oh no I wonder if he likes me next
video like we just kept going and then
by the end of the day it felt like you
softened up a little bit but like you
heard me talk for like five or six hours
so I guess you were just like cool with
it but I remember you saying that you
know that was the first thing you said
but the funniest thing about it the best
part about it is the in retrospect
knowing you now you don't give a [ __ ] if
you somebody get stuck in the comments
and probably the way that I handled it
you were like oh okay [ __ ] care I
mean for sure I feel like you know with
me because I say the things that I want
some people are like oh [ __ ] you know I
try to be very tactful with my words but
at the same time I'm kind of always been
unapologetically myself which has always
been an issue in terms of like when I
was younger it was hard for me to make
friends that way right because I
wouldn't socially navigate things if I
didn't want to right and if I'm now that
I'm older I'm just comfortable with
myself and I have this it's like oh this
is Who I am
I'm respectful but this is who I am you
know so it's like oh I can see that too
and I think like Muriel says sometimes
like I'm I could be very intimidating
when I want to be he is like URI I have
a duality to me it's like if you're
around people that you really respect
you can see how timid I get right but
it's around people who I don't know she
was like you're like you puff out your
chest a little bit it's like okay this
is who I am I think I think you and I
both were very polarizing people yeah
and
and I'm ok with that I know that about
myself now like either you love me or
you hate me and and honestly I think
that I like that more than just being
neutral all the time because with the
hate comes even as hate is a strong
emotion and some people really do
[ __ ] hate me like my branding is just
not for them over sir I know people hate
me yeah but that's such a strong emotion
on one end of it it makes the love even
stronger and that's what I found and and
I like that so do the the families in
the community that like I've been able
to kind of cultivate it's like I learned
a lot of these [ __ ] are kind of
like me and I feel comfortable in my own
community and that's what I love about
like how we we're not like brands like
we're [ __ ] people and we say what we
want and we do what we want and then in
turn you have people that you feel
comfortable with like in in your sphere
and even beyond that to it's not even
people who are like you it's people who
they kind of see great qualities in you
and they want that to be them as well
right so they they want to be like this
is the funniest [ __ ] thing I went to
this one show this is a kid I was trying
not to die laughing in front of his face
and this guy was like a Chinese he was
like a Fabio kid yeah it comes up I
don't know fabi's offensive but I'm a
fob so I don't go [ __ ] but he comes up
and he goes he goes and he's threw me
off machine hey David I just want to let
you know that I learned how to [ __ ]
cus from you man [ __ ] singing I
was like yeah I don't give up [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] about anything man I'm
like holy [ __ ] yo bro you ain't gotta go
off like that you ain't gotta curse all
the [ __ ] time but you know what he
told me to after he got done and with
this cursing diatribe he said that
watching somebody like me when he was
told to be the quiet timid person and he
had a lot of stuff that he wanted to say
that he stopped caring so much he goes I
not so much he wanted to be me but he
wanted to take certain qualities about
me and he wanted to instill in himself I
think that's why sometimes you know with
the with the you know the small fan base
that we do have they do [ __ ] with us and
they're kind of taking a lot of the life
lessons that we've learned that we made
a lot of our own mistakes in and so
we're kind of instilling this like you
don't have to make these mistakes let me
make it for you so enjoy this and enjoy
the fruits of my labor but you know
David we're supposed to just take that
lesson and sit there because that's like
yes please take it because it is what it
is I'm sorry I'm still not open about it
that's my favorite phrase it is what it
is
it is remember slavery Thank You
Chancellor it is what it is Katie it is
what it is my god dude you're so [ __ ]
toned up so toned oh you know when
people have it good they just don't like
to see everybody else's situation they
don't want to empathize with it and
that's the sad part about this pudding
you're supposed to be Miss Universe ho
aren't you supposed to be like Miss
Molly I thought she was just like Miss
Malaysia she's Miss Universe she was
like one of them contestants I mean if
she was even in the show like I haven't
I haven't seen it before but I saw that
Sandra Bullock movie where she you know
we're sure going to cover I've seen that
[ __ ] and that's a lot of [ __ ] she was
up there she got responsibilities as a
Malaysian actress model and beauty
pageant titleholder who crowned Miss
Universe Malaysia 2017 you supposed that
see now I get it cuz she's only thinking
about the universe she's so above it oh
oh dude David I [ __ ] up you know what
though I I have no idea where we're
gonna be as a society in like a hundred
years sorry I'm this sounds like
conspiracy bows coming out but somebody
said something to me the other day that
I was like okay this is gonna sound
[ __ ] insane but I was like could it
be a possibility somebody said they were
like I'm not sure how long America is
gonna be around because you hear about
the great civilizations that fell and
they fell after there was so much
tyranny and violence that people started
splitting off and it never was a thought
to me that America could just cease to
exist and split up into different places
different ideologies I don't know what
do you think of that what didn't like
California want to be its own country
for a hot second I think so yeah and
they were like this is not work I mean
if
I mean the United States is so split
right if you really think about it to
ours our national sense of identity we
don't really have one yeah true you
don't really have one that's why when
this whole COBIT pandemic happened right
and we're making these comparisons to
how other country men are dealing with
their countrymen and countrywomen are
dealing with their situation they came
all together as a collective they go
this is Korea this is Japan we got to
make sure we take care of one another we
have never really been about that in
this country it's been about me me me
what you're going through [ __ ] that I
got to worry about myself so maybe
that's the ideal ideology of what
America is so it makes it very difficult
so I could see this country splitting to
be honest with you I just don't think
the government will allow it I think
that they'll [ __ ] murder people
before they allow you to split it's a
seed from the nation and you know why
they'll do it because it weakens their
military 100% that's literally why don't
[ __ ] do it too that's literally why
they would want because otherwise it
could just be like oh you Florida
Florida could go be his own [ __ ]
country like I don't know but that I I
just never I never thought about that
because there are like we hear about
like what is that like the Romans the
Romans were the greatest in America is
the greatest right now I don't know what
the do you know happened to the Romans I
don't know how they like the [ __ ] babies
though or some [ __ ] oh yeah well you
know I heard that about Trump to [ __ ]
this is such a great podcast he said
that one random fact they [ __ ] baby yes
this episode of the genius best [ __ ]
don't ever know just like that's the
Davis no papa
there it is yeah but bosz working they
find you ice cream Mondays on twitch
that that's where you'll find me
consistently every Monday at 5 or 6 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time is twitch.tv slash
Big West close otherwise check out my
socials twitter i have a lot of yoga
David I'm gonna catch you up I've got
some crazy [ __ ] oh just follow me on
social we'll give you all the updates
yep you vikas genius brain podcasts on
basically anything and every [ __ ]
audio platform out there we try to be
the biggest the best as this is the
podcast where basically I'm just here to
keep you company through your [ __ ]
boring ass days because my days are
boring too and sometimes I even listen
to my own podcast what the [ __ ] I'm
saying like Romans [ __ ] babies and that
right there my friends is where we're
going to end it